without a doubt violent rioters looters
arsonists who are capitalizing on the
horrific death of George Floyd are sick
their twisted individuals that should be
locked up for a very long time so while
leaders on both sides of the aisle this
this is not an issue everybody that sees
this video pretty much in agreement with
maybe the exception of a few keyboard
warriors in their underwear in their
basements talking to themselves but for
the most part there is unanimous
agreement on this that in other words
what was we all watch with our own eyes
can happen in this country people
rightfully demand justice for George
Floyd by the way well they also seek
justice a lot of other people now have
been severely injured some killed in
these violent riots in the aftermath
that we have been witnessing the last
number of nights oh they got a demand
for example justice look at st. Louis
Police Captain David Doran remember he
was shot and killed by looters what
about the four other st. Louis police
officers who were shot during violent
protests will they demand justice for
the Vegas officer in critical condition
shot in the back of the head by a rioter
or the three Buffalo New York officers
who are intentionally run over by a
person in a car or the three police
officers in Davenport Iowa who were
ambushed by a rioter with a gun or the
two officers at Richmond Virginia that
were shot or the Federal Protective
Services officer who was shot and killed
and we can go on and on all violent this
is unacceptable
look at New York City an arc II has been
particularly bad and out of control one
NYPD officer was mowed down by a rioter
in a car
another officer beaten by an angry mob
so far over 30 members of the NYPD have
been injured by rioters some of those
injuries very critical and serious and
we can't forget about widespread looting
destruction arson fires 5th Avenue was
looted Macy's Herald Square their
flagship store you know Thanksgiving Day
Parade Miracle on 34th Street Macy's
yeah
no business safe from criminals these
are criminals it's not part of a
peaceful protest
according to reports organized crime may
have coordinated some of the looting but
comrade Mayor Bill DeBlasio
he's just been pretending that
everything's fine and dandy take a look
at this side-by-side comparison we call
it de Blasio versus reality take a look
overall even in a day where thousands of
people were out expressing their views
expressing their frustration their pain
their anger their deep desire for change
in locations all over the city overall
what we saw was overwhelmingly peaceful
demonstration definitely going to
address some of the things we saw late
in the evening that were not peaceful
and not acceptable but if you talk about
the reality of the full day we saw more
and more the peaceful demonstrators
coming to the floor he has to be among
the dumbest politicians and that's
saying something in the entire world
even yesterday after days of riots
violence beat downs lootings all comrade
de Blasio feeling nostalgic even
reminiscing about his favorite song John
Lennon's Imagine take a look I
understand I don't mean to make light of
this but I'm reminded of the song
imagine by John Lennon we played it at
my inauguration I I think everyone who
hears that song and his fullness thinks
about what about a world where people
got along differently what about a world
where we didn't live with a lot of the
restrictions that we live with now but
we're not there yet we are making a lot
of progress him reminisce all he want
his police officers as mayor Giuliani's
been telling him and warning him for
days on end are under attack and thanks
to New York's absolute insane bail
reform and Governor Cuomo's bill and he
signs it most crimes now require as soon
as you get arrested no bail whatsoever
so police then they are forced to now
deal with the same criminals night after
night after night in January there was a
guy that robbed four different banks
released from jail under this policy
just to go out
robbed another one get arrested again go
rob another one that's how insane that
is and now we're likely seeing with the
same thing with the looters the rioters
and the arsons however New York's
attorney who was arrested for throwing
that Molotov cocktail into a police car
well he was forced to post bail a
miracle lucky for her former Obama Intel
official actually helped post the bail
for her Wow
and meanwhile according to a brand-new
Fox news.com report the black lives
matter foundation is apparently
preparing for a quote war on police now
they're reporting training a bunch of
armed individuals to protect their
community from law enforcement they're
calling themselves peace officers now
keep in mind
okay black lives matter they have a
mission eradicate white supremacy no
American no good American is bigoted or
racist okay you have to protect every
American and every American's rights I
agree with that too all good Americans
stand against racism and bigotry but
apparently now they're willing to do it
what an armed militia how do we
interpret that in other words they want
to push the police out of neighborhoods
they're the neighborhood's first line of
defense you're going to replace them
with your arm to militia
let's just say I don't have any
confidence at night.i idea